die haben übrigens wirklich gesagt wir nehmen
gar nicht so viel Geld also weil das war jetzt
halt witzig gemeint wegen Kapitalismus
und ich habe ja sehen Sie und so willst
du Komiker halt ist nicht alles witzig und
heute ist auch so ein bisschen ich muss
mich ein bisschen rechtfertigen wie bekommen
halt regelmäßig Zuschriften und das meiste
mehr so eine Art Aufruf hör doch mal auf deshalb
bald Aufruf und wir bekommen halt auch regelmäßig
gerne das ist auch immer wenn zwei Arten von
Nummern kommen also immer wenn ich irgendwas
über kleine Tiere mache dann kommt immer letztes
Mal habe ich über eine kleine Katze die man an
der Tisch es war auch blöd aber man muss das
mehr im Zusammenhang betrachten und Kinder
sollte man auch nicht so machen und ich möchte
das jetzt nutzen um einfach auch mal zu sagen dass
Sie wirklich wissen also ich mag Kinder wenn ich
hier Witze über Kinder mal das sind Witze also ich
esse die nicht zu Hause sondern es ist ganz normal
ich mag Kinder wirklich ich glaube ich habe sogar
welche also ist man weiß schnell und ich möchte
nein ich liebe Kinder ja aber halt auf eine gute
Art also muss man ja ja sehen Sie das jetzt geht
schon wieder los sagt sie nein und wir lieben ja
alle Kinder ich meine wie stehen sie Kinder sind
doch unsere Zukunft oder wir was wie stehen sie
Kinder gegenüber das sind doch die einzigen
die uns noch retten können Kinder und deshalb
kaufen wir den ja auch diese diese Kinderwagen für
anderthalb Tausend Euro oder dass sie auch schon
ab dem 3 Monat in der Kita können damit weil wir
die so lieb haben und so gerne auch um uns herum
Kinder sind so und es gibt ja auch schon Polo
Hemdchen mit ganz großen Logo also manchmal
frage ich mich ist das jetzt nicht auf Instagram
oder tatsächlich ein Kind aber gut wir brauchen
Sie auch gerne mal als status symbol wobei das
Kind selbst nicht ist es nur der Träger des
status symbols und ich bin ein großer Fan
von Kindern und das hat sich auch bei uns
so in der Nachbarschaft herumgesprochen weil ich
mache den Kindern in der Nachbarschaft den mache
ich gern Geschenke ja wirklich ich bin so der
nette Onkel also der gute nette Onkel nicht der
mit dem Lolli sondern der man muss es ich muss
jetzt sehr vorsichtig sein so und weil z.B zu
dem Nachbar gehen habe ich ein sehr sehr gutes
Verhältnis der hat immer gesagt oh ich wünsche
mir ich wünsche mir so einen Chemiebaukasten von
von Kosmos und da habe ich gesagt komm mach sie
immer und da habe ich mir aber gedacht
du der von Cosmos der ist ja langweilig
und ob ich in der Apotheke und habe mir gedacht
damit das auch irgendwie mehr so Esprit und
Wumms hat habe ich ihm halt Phosphor Natron
und Zucker besorgt weil ich irgendwo gelesen
hatte das war so eine islamistische auf jeden
Fall da hatten die Daten die so ein Rezept
und dann dachte ich das wird ein Knaller
und wirklich der macht Fortschritte die
hatten früher so ein Anbau rechts neben dem
Haus da ist jetzt und ich habe vorgeschlagen
weil die natürlich da habe ich dann gesagt komm
willst du mal willst du mal nicht so sein die habe
ich dann so ein Löffelchen und so ein Gürtel für
den Oberarm geschenkt und dem Bild wann wir Kinder
vom Bahnhof ja die ist gerade in der Pubertät
ne und die muss ich finden und da dachte ich
Mensch das ganze noch mal ausprobieren ja dann
weiß ich schon mal was er will oder nicht will
und so macht jetzt immer ich spiele auch gerne mit
den Nachbars gehen dann Räuber und dann aber halt
richtig ich habe so 20 Gotcha Gewehre besorgt
und Kabelbinder bei uns nebenan ist nicht JVA
und die Freigänger die passen wir dann immer
ab die Jacke du darfst es nicht zum Nahkampf
kommen lassen die knackig sind sehr gut also aber
wenn der halt so ein fünfjährigen umhaut das ist
ja auch Lerneffekt für den also für beide und
und so lebe ich also ich verstecke auch gerne
so ja genau und ja apropos ich verstehe auch gerne
Glasscheiben Scherben im Sandkasten vom Spielplatz
verschenke Kampfhunde und sowas und das war ja
pass auf jetzt denken Sie sich jetzt aber wieder
eine andere Klatsche nee nee weil damit wir nur
ich liebe Kinder weil mal ganz ehrlich was ist
denn der große Unterschied ob ich den jetzt ein
bisschen quecksilbern Geburtstagskuchen mische
oder aber ob mir diese klimawärmung total egal
ist oder wir benutzen unsere Umwelt da draußen
doch wirklich brauchen sie wir fahren mit SUVs
da draußen in der Gegend rum die verbrauchen
30 Liter auf 100 km angeblich steigen diese
diese Ozean Meeresspiegel und uns ist es doch
scheißegal nachhaltig Ortsansicht das ist uns
doch egal wie propagieren das aber wir machen
nichts und im Endeffekt nehmen wir doch den
Kindern die Zukunft die sind uns scheißegal
sie treten ein Kind jeden Tag in die Fresse wenn
sie für zwei Kilometer ihr Auto anschmeißen die
Reichen mit ihren status symbol warum kaufen
die sich nicht die Elektroautos warum müssen
die strange Rover da rumfahren du kannst
auch ein BMW darf ich nicht sagen ist egal
kaufen die sind doch die die sich das leisten
können was machen die nicht im Grunde genommen
ist das jedes Mal das Gleiche und ich kann es
nicht haben ich kann es nicht haben wir können
so viel verändern wir können so viel machen
indem wir uns einfach mal über die Konsequenzen
im Klaren sind was wir da draußen alles falsch
machen wenn Sie jetzt denken oh jetzt ist er da
vorne aber wirklich also ja bin ich bin ich
wirklich ich gehe jetzt auch mit den Nadeln
ich habe ich habe jetzt wieder ich gehe ich
ich ziehe das mit den Nachbarskindern durch
weil im Grunde genommen es ist ja wenn ich dir
auf die Apokalypse vorbereitet sind die dir viel
besser gestellt als irgendwelche Eltern die den
irgendwelche Sicherheiten vor heucheln nur um
hinter dir einen rücken die Welt da draußen zu
zerstören jeder da draußen lebt doch im Grunde
genommen nur nach der Maxime hoffentlich schaffe
ich es bis zum Sterbebett und wenn es dann da
geschafft haben sagen wir puh ein Glück geschafft
ich gehe mit den Nachbars Kindern jetzt hinten im
Zoo nächstes Wochenende wir wollen da die Tiere
vergiften ja natürlich dann können die wenigstens
noch Mal tschüss sagen und nachfolgende Generation
wissen nicht was du verpassen das hat System und
bitte schreiben Sie mir jetzt keinen Brief sparen
Sie sich lieber das Porto und wenn Sie das an
irgendeine Umweltorganisation die ist wirklich
verdient hat mal drüber nachdenken [Gelächter] war
schon witzig übrigens davon gibt es noch mehr
wenn Sie das hier abonnieren also drücken
ich muss mal aufs Klo